when the sun rose on that fateful day
Jerry marks had been one of the lucky
ones he worked in a mine deep
underground at the edge of a small town
in the rural United States which meant
he didn't see what happened when day
broke when the light of the sun ravaged
the Earth the first Jerry heard about it
was when his son Kyle came racing into
the mine frantically tapping his dad's
shoulder to get his attention he'd run
all the way from their tiny Homestead
under a fireproof blanket thick and long
enough to block the sunlight from
touching any part of Kyle's skin his
older sister Jerry's daughter Carly
hadn't been so lucky caught by the Light
her body had turned to the consistency
of warm candle wax melting into a form
that barely resembled human anymore
Jerry had been one of a handful of
others working late in the mines that
day a few thought that young Kyle had
made the whole story up and ventured up
to the surface and into the quiet only
to meet the same Twisted Fate the light
morphed their bodies into monstrosities
anyone small rural community becoming an
amorphous mass of human flesh eventually
those that stayed behind in the mine
heard the voices of their loved ones
their wives husbands children all
calling out to them from outside they
promised that nothing was wrong that it
was a lovely sunny day outside and the
Mine Workers should clock out to come
and enjoy it more of them left reassured
by hearing their families that all was
well and once more none of them were
seen again only Jerry and Kyle were left
and it stayed that way for several
months the father and son had to adapt
to life underground only leaving the
mind to forage for food and only while
wearing thick dirty mining overalls
making sure not a single millimeter of
skin was on display if the sunlight
touched them they'd never make it back
alive venturing out of the mine in his
overalls Jerry had seen the shuffling
melted mass that had once been
Townsville he did his best to avoid it
as he went house to house making sure it
never saw him while he raided cupboards
and refrigerators but he could see it
and among the Blobs of bodies Blended
together he saw something that resembled
his daughter it turned his stomach not
just knowing but actually witnessing
what had happened to her and it was made
all the worse on the days that Carly
called out to him and Kyle while they
hid in the mine it was clearly her voice
but there was something wrong about it
perhaps knowing that she was a part of
the melted monstrosity made it easier to
resist her trying to coax them out into
the light it had almost been an entire
year of Life spent Underground when
Jerry and Kyle encountered their first
actual human beings since all the other
workers had left the mine the pair that
arrived were strange wearing protective
suits that covered them both head to toe
just like Jerry and Kyle had quickly
realized these two two were aware that
not even the tiniest hint of the Sun's
unforgiving light could be allowed to
reach them the two approached Jerry and
Kyle seemingly coming in peace although
the Father and Son remained cautious of
the newcomers making sure they were deep
enough in the mind to avoid the sunlight
at these Stony entrance the pair of them
revealed their faces confirming they
were still fully human before
introducing themselves as researcher
worth and Sergeant Booker of the SCP
Foundation sitting down with Jerry worth
explained what had really happened he
had been working for an organization
that contained and studied anomalous
creatures and phenomena the foundation
Booker had been a member of a special
armed unit within the same establishment
or a mobile task force but now the SCP
Foundation itself had fallen with a
number of its own Personnel turned into
more of the amorphous fleshy creatures
in the sunlight we spent a lot of years
keeping all this from the public worth
admitted sounding guilty but implying
the choice was out of his hands but I
don't suppose there's any point in
Secrets anymore it's the sun you see Mr
Marks ah you can call me Jerry he
interrupted sorry Jerry worth corrected
himself but something happened to the
sun it changed decimated the entire
planet in barely any time at all I mean
all those people millions billions all
at once dear God worth took a moment as
the existential dread of it all once
again caught up with him it turned out
the biggest anomaly was right above us
Booker continued for him she sounded a
lot more stoic even a little coldly
detached from it all
scp-001 that's what the foundation
called it is there a way to reverse it
or cure the people that the sunlight you
know changes Jerry asked thinking of
Carly you mean
scp-001-a no I'm sorry Jerry there's
nothing we can do the researcher said
failing to sound as recomposed as he
pretended to be your daughter is gone
but at least you still have your worth
paused looking around at the mine even
in the low light there was no sign of
Kyle Jerry turned to scan the area to
his horror his son had seemed to
vanished while they were talking
instantly Panic caused him to think that
Kyle had wandered out of the mine and
into the sunlight turning into part of
what worth had called
scp-001-a but the boy would have had to
walk past Jerry to start heading that
direction plus the father knew his son
was far too scared to go outside after
seeing what the sun had done to Carly
Booker had a tactical bag filled with
equipment flashlights spare batteries
even flares for whenever the power in
those ran out and both working and
living in the mine so long Jerry had
Maps knew certain routes through the
Deep network of tunnels almost by heart
between them the three had enough to
mount a search for the missing boy
keeping together they traversed away
from the first of several large Chambers
down into the dark depths of the mine
hell his father yelled his voice echoing
through the tunnel Kyle body it's down
head you there walking behind him
researcher worth and Sergeant Booker
parroted the calls assuring the missing
boy that they didn't mean him or Jerry
any harm as the trio walked deeper and
deeper they began to venture into a
portion of the mine that had hardly been
used by the workers it was darker than
the areas for the rough while those had
rows of electric lamps powered by long
cables attached to generators down here
the only light came from the flashlights
the group carried Kyle come on Al Jerry
called out for his son again this isn't
the time to split up we need to stick
together come on son I'm really worried
here once again there was no answer just
then Jerry caught the set of Booker and
worth out of the corner of his eye both
of them knew a lot about scp-001 and the
mine worker couldn't help the suspicion
that added to his perception of them
after all Kyle had never run off before
now and Jerry couldn't help but think
while his attention had been turned that
the para Foundation Personnel had taken
his son dad a voice suddenly called out
Jerry's head spun on a swivel at the
sound of Kyle calling for him Dad where
are you it echoed through the tunnel
again that's him Jerry exclaimed to the
other two which way did that come from
Straight Ahead it sounds like Booker
replied hold on with interjected I think
you two should look at this the beam
from his flashlight was pointed at the
rocky floor of the tunnel something was
gleaming wet against the stone a large
smear of red like something had been
dragged in the direction Kyle's voice
was coming from oh God he could be hurt
Jerry said urgently hurt might not be
the right word I'm afraid Jerry the
researcher said solemnly there's a lot
of blood here too much all the more
reason to go further and find where he's
calling from the father retorted angrily
that's if it is the kid that's actually
calling us Booker replied her and worth
exchanging a worried glance at each
other you two know something don't you
Jerry demanded does that thing from the
outside does it have my son too Dad
another other voice called Jerry froze
his blood as cold as the mine tunnel who
stood in he hadn't heard that voice in
almost a year but recognized it
immediately it was Carly his daughter it
seemed impossible he knew she had been
merged into part of
scp-001-a when day broke but now she was
somehow calling out to Jerry her voice
sounded clearer like it had used to
before she changed and she wasn't trying
to lure her father out into the sunlight
either for a moment it seemed to Jerry
like his daughter had somehow come back
dad were both over here Carly's voice
called again we need your help Kyle's
stuck who's that Booker whispered that's
Carly Jerry sniffed holding back tears
you said your daughter became a part of
scp-001-a worth pointed out maybe she
got better the father asked hopefully I
hate to say it but that's definitely not
her Sergeant Booker replied we should
turn back now if there's an anomaly in
these tunnels it's not going to be
pretty for any of us she added turning
to worth what Jerry out what do you mean
by that look buddy those aren't your
children the MTF agent said bluntly it
sounded like scp-001-8 got them no no
the the voices are too clear worth
replied I think something else is in
here before Jerry could explode with
anger at how uninterested both
Foundation Personnel seemed at the fate
of his children another sound Was Heard
footsteps something shuffling closer
patting its feet on the stone there was
a low growl that filled the tunnel as
whatever it was came closer still dad
the voice of Carly repeated sounding
only a few feet away now where are you
Dad Kyle's voice immediately followed it
behind came the sound of Booker striking
a flare as it erupted into a plume of
light and heat she threw it down the
tunnel and there they were not Jerry's
children but instead a pair of
nightmarish creatures they backed away
from the flare slightly the light still
illuminate their blood red forms walking
on all fours like wolves the creatures
elongated heads were missing any eyes
just Jaws filled with rows of sharp Red
Fangs dad came Kyle's voice again
emanating from one of the monsters it
was mimicking Jerry's son both of his
kids even having seen
scp-001-a at a distance the father could
barely believe his eyes 9 39s Booker
yelled II her flare illuminated them run
she pulled the sidearm and opened fire
the bang of each shot ringing loudly
through the tunnel the pair of 939s
pounced at her while jerion worth turned
to run back the way they had come as the
creatures attacked The Echoes of the
gunfire were replaced with blood
curdling screams what the hell are those
things Jerry yelled in a panic SC 3939
researcher worth painted too much to
explain they're pack hunters and they're
and they're vicious what about Kyle and
Carly I heard their voices that's what
those monsters do they mimic human
speech to draw us out wear their prey
there's no telling how long they've been
down here they might have retreated to
the mine to avoid the sun on the surface
worth yelled the sound of the scp-939 is
getting closer were catching up right on
Jerry and Worth's heels why would they
come down here for the mine worker
huffed slightly ahead of the researcher
given his slightly stronger physique to
escape the sunlight worth replied
scp-939's hate Brian
yeah
his sentence was overtaken by a scream
as one of the blood red creatures caught
worth by the ankle knocking him down and
pulling him back to be devoured Jerry
didn't look back he just kept running
back through the tunnel the sound of
scp-939 calling after him and Kyle and
Carly's voices made it even harder not
to stop and turn even just for a second
but he reminded himself that if he
stopped running then he couldn't lure
the creatures out of a mine and into the
sunlight it wasn't how he'd ever wanted
to go out but maybe that way Jerry would
see his kids again now go and check out
scp-001 can scp-049 finally cure when
day breaks and scp-001 when day breaks
scp-682 for more horrifying when
Daybreak scenarios